Hey comedy. Huh? You can see anal and Asians and Jews.
I'm working on it. Peel. I say, Mark, gotta be more confident. I say,
Mark gotta be yourself. I'm like, you got to pick one.
Hey delivery. I'm working on my delivery too, buddy. Corona has been so long.
It feels like the check engine light. You know, at first you're scared of it.
Then after a while you're like, it. I gotta go to work. You give it a snuff.
The ladies, all your sexual stuff. That's all under wraps. Very hush,
hush men walk around. I'm an man. I'm a boob man ever see a woman go.
I'm a ball gal. Yeah. I love that sack.
I don't care if a lesbian compliments me, nothing gets lesbians,
but that doesn't help. My ego. You have a lesbian is like, Hey Mark.
Like a haircut. I'm like, I know he have the same one. These poor kids.
They got to go to school at home. Now they're all homeschooled. You know,
that's sad.
How long until a teacher in Florida has cybersex with one of her students,
you know, what's going to happen here.
Like in the fifties we had whites only and blacks only water fountain,
which is incredibly sad. Especially if you're a thirsty Asian.
Yeah.
What the hell are they doing? Drinking out of a faucet? No one talks about it.
Never come up once. Not a peep. Hey, good to be here. It's a, it's a pleasure.
I'm a little hung over a little gay, but uh,
just glad to be here with you, sister.
I don't know if any of you guys have kids that sucks for you guys with the
schools being closed. It's actually good for me though.
Cause now I can drive by them again. Like ladies, you know,
when you go out to dinner with a guy or like just cause you bought me dinner
doesn't mean I hear you six and that's true.
But just because you let me have sex with you, it doesn't mean I own my morning.
Right? It's the same exact transaction equality, right?
This crowd's like anal. It takes a minute, you know? Oh,
this looks like you guys are waiting for a God smack to come on. Uh,
just me gonna make fun of some Jews and we'll all pack it up. I'm not racist.
I look at racism the same way I look at Nickelback. Yeah.
You know, it's uh, it's fun to joke about, but uh,
you never want to see it live.
I'm hitting the streets to tell some jokes about this pandemic.
A lot of these flew right over people's head
I'm in therapy. Anybody else? Hey, there you go. A couple of people. Yeah.
You know, I'm doing this thing called exposure therapy. That's where your face,
your fears. Scared of Heights. You take the hot air balloon.
Scared of drowning takes you in the ocean. So he said, what are you scared of?
Mark? I'm claustrophobic and scared of intimacy.
So he took me a little closet and me.
Wasn't getting a hand job at the moment in the car. Oh, that guy. All right.
Well done, sir. I didn't know. The hand job was still around.
I'm pitching these shows. That'll never get sold and I'm at the Fox lot.
And you walk in. There's a big parking lot is a beautiful day.
This is open air courtyard. All these girls have their shoes kicked off.
They get their feet up on the table. There they're smoking vape pens.
They're drinking a coffee. They got the sunglasses on. I'm like,
you don't know what you got. This is amazing. You don't appreciate it.
I know of any of it. This is your job. You're getting paid.
Probably like a hundred grand a year. We're going to at TV.
You're in show business. You got your shoes off at work. Yeah. You're living it,
living it. And they don't even know. They're like, uh,
Uber eats is taking a while and you're like, shut up. Cut.
You're you're you're living the dream. Well, he's like a high maintenance chick.
Like you want to get inside me? You gotta here an hour early.
Take your shoes off and do a body scan. You're like Jesus Christ.
I think I'm autistic. But just like the bad parts of it, you know?
Like I can't compute numbers or remember dates, but I'll make you feel weird.
Ah,
she whizzing. Okay. He's probably doing heroin in the Bordeaux. I get it.
Good to have you back. How was that? Uh, heroin. There we are. All right.
Thanks for coming up. Great cleavage. I just put a special out.
I had a chatty Uber driver last week. That's the worst. Huh?
This guy wouldn't shut up. I forgot that the no smalltalk option on the app.
So I'd get creative. I just scare the guy into being quiet. He's like,
how about this traffic? Huh? What are the things causing this?
I'm like probably the Jews. He's like
[inaudible] I love a roof gig. This goes horribly. I can just jump right off.
Now. You guys are more of a, maybe a query thing. Oh my gosh. Is it,
is it clean? Don't worry. I'm not cheating. These swastikas I've drawn air, um,
jokes, jokes. It does feel like at the end of this,
we're going to sacrifice a liberal. Doesn't it? She was like, you know,
I feel very brave tonight. I was like, why is that?
Because I'm not wearing any makeup. I was like, how's that brave?
Because I'm being my true self being the real me. I was like, Oh, okay.
She's like, you should be brave. I'm like, yeah, maybe I will. She's like,
what are you going to do? I was, I'm going to stop pretending.
This is interesting.
[inaudible] so I wrote just a ton of. I got Corona, I got riots.
I got anal. I feel like a, like a woman in arranged marriage. You know, I,
uh, I didn't choose this. I got to cover my face. And if I say my opinion,
I get yelled at. You're allowed to be hateful in America,
as long as you're not specific. And that weird. If you're like,
I hate Mexican people. Everybody's like, Oh my God, what a bigot prejudice.
But if you're like, I hate people. Everybody's like right.
Hey, good to be here. Thank you for being here. Appreciate you having me.
I'm hurting there, right? Hey,
that's why I'm a comedian because I got to get love somewhere. Whoops. Sorry.
Is that a meal? This is my first standup set back in like 84,
84 days. The hoops a lady with oops.
You can only tell a crazy woman. It's about the size of groups, right?
That's where this comes from. Somebody write that down.
How about that? Fowchee? He's a bummer. Huh? I get, he's got a hard job,
but felt she was like a,
he's like a COVID Groundhog and hit out every time I see him on TV. I'm like.
Another six weeks of pandemic. I just watched a documentary on pedophile.
My friend, my friend goes, Oh, I could never have sex with a kid.
They're so annoying.
I was like, that's it? Huh?
The NBA's we're with it. The empty stands. No,
we should do just to fill those up.
Let's take the racist statues and put them in the stands. Yeah,
like guys like that one. Alright. Why are you scared to laugh now?
Why these there is comedy.
Thanks a lot. I'm Kevin
[inaudible].